they make it their business to mind your
business in Oregon lawn chair balloonist
is grounded by the FAA and the high cost
of helium and check out what's happening
across the pond when it comes to the
Internet in the balance between freedom
and responsibility we've neglected our
responsibility to children although it's
touted as a way to protect children the
Brits are veering toward Iceland in
Saudi Arabia for that matter by
implementing far-reaching restrictions
on internet porn with is time Danny the
month heads down south some groups are
already expressing outrage over proposed
changes to the city's
anti-discrimination ordinance in San
Antonio some officials want to add
sexual orientation and gender identity
to the city's list of protected
categories the ordinance would forbid
bias by word or deed it would apply to
pass words and deeds as well some claim
the ordinance would ban Christians from
public office trample the First
Amendment and meddle in the political
process by prying into people's past
others claim right-wingers are just
hyping an imaginary threat who's right
well we ran the ordinance by UCLA First
Amendment scholar Eugene bullet he says
it would not apply to elected office as
some have claimed but it would affect
appointed positions like serving on
boards or commissions turns out the text
of the ordinance is much broader than
many of its supporters realize for
instance participating in the Boy Scouts
if it involves a plan to organizations
membership policy we're speaking out
against same-sex marriage could
disqualify someone from appointed office
as volatile even if that someone has a
change of heart the councilman pushing
for the revision may end up backing off
but even the current ordinance forbids
all kinds of speech for instance saying
conservative Christians are stupid for
saying that men are better or worse at
something than women follow me the month
on Twitter submit your nanny nominees
and click here to watch another episode
you